emergency services rushed to the scene
but it took time to access the six
storey building located in a congested
area of Delhi's old city where narrow
lanes are lined with small manufacturing
and storage units we received a call at
5:22 a.m. and we initially sent for fire
service trucks to the spot and in total
35 vehicles 150 people were deployed the
rescued survivors have been sent to
different hospitals in the city the
workshop produced handbags and luggage
and flammable raw materials evidently
fueled the fire as it swept through the
building one eyewitness blamed
electrical faults for the blaze it was a
short circuit there was a fire in two
buildings with a common staircase as
authorities launched their
investigations questions have already
arisen as to whether the factory was
operating with valid permit and was
following fire safety codes
correspondent nimisha jaiswal has been
tracking this story for us she joins us
now from Delhi
what more first of all do we know about
the fire so far well we know that the
first call about the incident was made
very early local time shortly after 5:00
a.m. and 30 fire tenders were rushed to
the spot - and this area where the a
fire broke out is actually very
congested it's also got residential
complexes and this factory is basically
a small workshop there is a collection
of small workshops in the area and the
fire originated in a bag manufacturing
unit and rescue operations continue
through the morning the fire was
controlled pretty soon but there has
been a heavy loss of life a lot of
authorities a law enforcement as well as
politicians are showing up at the store
at the spot and the Chief Minister of
Delhi has already said that that an
urgent inquiry will be instituted and
within seven days they should have a
report about what exactly was the cause
of the fire maybe show that the death
toll there is high we hear it's expected
to rise what more do we know about the
conditions in and
around this building well called the
death toll is mostly people who were
actually working in the factory and they
were actually sleeping in the factory
it's important to point out that
questions are being raised about if this
factory was legal or not
so actually fire safety norms may not
have been abided by but even more
importantly labor norms may not have
been abided by and these workers could
have been sleeping in the factory at 5
a.m. because it is cheaper to stay there
it is quicker it is more efficient for
them to start working early so these
norms were not being met and this is not
the first such fire incident in the city
just last year in January 17 people lost
their lives at an illegal firecracker
Factory so their norms that are supposed
to be instituted across the city but
they're not implemented as closely so
officials will be looking into how to
improve this as well once they figure
out what exactly happened here so sadly
not the first time that we've seen a
fire claimed dozens of lives in the city
how were authorities now responding well
as I said called the Chief Minister has
said that there will be an investigation
but even political leaders higher up are
weighing in the Prime Minister Prime
Minister Narendra Modi put out a
statement on Twitter saying that the
incident was very tragic and he's sent
his condolences to the families of the
victims there's been compensation
announced to the families of the victims
by the state government as well the home
Minister's responded that the president
has weighed in but of course while the
authorities are reacting quickly to this
what will be crucial is if any of these
implementations any of these norms will
actually be changed going forward
because as you said these incidences
keep repeating Nimisha jaiswal covering
that fire for us in Delhi thank you very
much